so the final trailer's gone online for
the conclusion of the saga of thorin
oaken
what
they're still calling it the hobbit
really
so the new trailer for the hobbit battle
of the five armies is out and i gotta be
honest i wasn't planning to talk about
this thing partially because i'm uh
getting over cold but funny thing i
actually got a request to talk about
this and with as few subscribers as i
have i'm not about to ignore that so you
guys this one
this is for you you know if you saw my
thoughts on the first teaser that showed
up for this movie you're gonna hear a
lot of the same stuff this is not
bilbo's story i'll grant you this he is
the first voice in the first character
that we actually see but you know what
the first word that comes out of his
mouth is
thorin
yes thorino concealed this has become
his story pretty much completely at this
point and i'm not saying that thorin's a
bad character but this shift just
completely emphasizes how badly these
movies missed the point of the book the
book is a fun jaunty adventure it's not
meant to be an epic yes he's helping
these dwarves and for them this is an
epic struggle but it's supposed to be
from the perspective of bilbo who's just
along for the ride he's there for the
adventure and there's no sense of
adventure in this thing because they've
gone too big too spectacled too ominous
and i'm gonna consider this a potential
spoiler you know the part in the trailer
will bilbo takes the ring and he puts
the ring on and vanishes that's like
it's towards the end
that is the entirety of his involvement
in the battle of the five armies bilbo
does not take part in this thing he puts
the ring on and hides now that's in the
book i'm sure they'll have him skewered
somebody with his sword at some point
just to try in some sort of lip service
manner to validate the title of the
hobbit but the battle of five armies
isn't the point it's not the massive
climax conclusion of this story it's a
footnote it's an afterthought the climax
of the story is smile gets the dragon
that is what everything is building
towards that is what the climax of the
book is yes the battle of the five
armies happens but again because it's
from bilbo's perspective very little
time is spent on it because he's not an
active participant and now they're gonna
basically spend an entire movie on this
one battle and they're trying to go
bigger than helms deep they're trying to
go bigger than the battle for the
palador fields the trailer has the
audacity to call this battle the
defining moment of the middle earth
legend
what
i'm sorry unless you were really heavily
into these books and had just read the
hobbit once read lord of the rings once
there's a pretty good chance you didn't
even remember the battle of the five
armies happened
and you know i've now realized exactly
why they pulled the complete bs ending
they did at the end of desolation of
smaug because if they'd finish that
story with what is the very obvious way
that it has to end and you know what i'm
not even gonna consider this a spoiler
if you were paying attention at all you
know exactly how this is gonna play out
and exactly how the dragon is gonna die
yes the dragon dies i mean you should
have guessed that by now he's nowhere to
be seen in this new trailer you know why
they're going to wrap him up within 20
minutes and the only reason it is being
held over was to make sure the audiences
came back because if they'd finished it
if they finished the story of the
desolation of smile and had ended where
it should have ended with the death of
the dragon people wouldn't have come
back they would have gone
stories over isn't it sure people would
have still come back but they wouldn't
have felt the driving need because it's
like well story's finished isn't it
that's what the battle of the five
armies is like story's finished didn't
it are we still going and to avoid them
having to have that kind of problem what
they do they cut it off 20 minutes
before the story actually ends so that
they force audiences to come back to
catch the end of what should have been
the end of the last movie and then they
string us along with
however long this battle is and it's a
battle it's ju it's one battle it's not
a war it's not a series of skirmishes
it's one
stupid
battle and i'm not saying stupid because
i'm annoyed with it the reason that it
happens is stupid i don't mean story i
don't mean structure i mean the
motivations and the reasons that
everything comes to a head and a battle
actually happens is a dumb reason it
makes sense it's consistent with the
characters but it's a stupid reason for
as many people to die as end up dying
which then makes it a very stupid thing
to make the central premise of your
movie and now to claim it's the defining
moment of the middle earth saga oh
bite me
this is bad i'm actually getting angrier
as i even talk about it i hadn't been
all that annoyed by the trailer because
honestly i hadn't given it that much
stuff but the more i think about it the
more i talk about it just the angrier i
get with what these movies are because i
don't think that my expectation of what
they should have been is that far off
the mark i thought they should have been
the hobbit
the book that i read and loved and
wanted to see on the screen and they're
not that it's the same characters that
set on middle earth but the feel is
completely wrong bilbo who is the title
character is completely sidelined the
whole thing it just drives me insane
i'm still gonna go to the theater check
it out because i've sunk the time for
the last two i might as well finish this
damn thing off so have you seen this
trailer for what will hopefully be the
last entry in the
what are they gonna call it now the
middle earth saga who even knows but
what did you think about the trailer did
it make you more excited did it make you
more angry did you even register that it
came out whatever it is drop something
down in the comments let's talk about it
until next time this council
is adjourned
you